pick up a nice change Hey look about
line good chatting with you buddy
now [ __ ] off [ __ ] idiots
oh we never been up here that way this
is like the Attic
what the [ __ ] are you doing hey hey hey
what a [ __ ]
hey I'm cool I'm cool
what the hell what are we go away I'm
mother by the way in a bit of lane where
do we go oh yeah it's the kitchen I'm in
a cage and chemicals at the Haven Wow
all right kept it that bad boy we've
been here yeah we've been here hey man
what are you thinking about girlfriend
left yeah well well I mean I can see why
no offense
that's all I got sorry I'm not a
therapist all right
third floor this is get to the third
floor and get this [ __ ] over with huh
how you doing sorry
okay that's cool I don't know where the
third floor is I don't know about your
breads bad yeah and it's not my Jane I
know I told you brother said I know
where the stairs are but I take that
[ __ ] back hey how you doing cool great
sorry i lo I needed Martinelli Emily
while I shall I get the hello Martin
Martin
confidential not anymore hey have you
ever seen Martin no well then I will
check in here ma Matt Dave Martin
stacked funds and further ahead mate
then maybe out the window yeah yeah of
course
Thanks idiot all right which way this
way
first morning got anything you thought
about it before I thought about it it
happens every time you who I'm there I
know about it
it's a gift what can I say hey you know
what Martin you see Martin
God hates sickness okay
God hates money yeah okay okay
God annoys provides way oh [ __ ] that's
not how the hell do you even get here
you guys are not welcomed this is my
town
okay let's get this over with
I'm sure there's nothing special my job
oh hey witness uh-huh the promise of the
prophets was always freedom from death
huh
my okay just tell him already
huh okay son
yep oh he's gonna burn
all right cool
hi hi hi hi come on
yeah
all right
you're not so tough now huh you're not
don't duck now huh yeah I don't think so
bakka
I'm out of here [ __ ] that place the
first thing I'm gonna do is have a
vanilla strawberry yogurt what the hell
did I just say
was it any but are the elevator of cost
sorry okay did you get for us it's been
one heck of an adventure
but now we're getting the [ __ ] out of
here what deaf Gabe [ __ ] Gabe he just
couldn't let us go cootie all right
don't worry
Oh Gabe Gabe Gabe I'm not gay game I'm
sorry accent ah what do we got out there
living here someone I swear to God did
stop find me please
I'm sorry whoa oh [ __ ] I forgot okay no
prob
don't panic don't panic don't panic okay
we're fine I think I'll be fine
whoa jump high that doesn't attend tada
laughs [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you done it now
[ __ ] you done diddly [ __ ] up pinion
all right we go ahead okay we got a note
I see it I see it they'll touch me bro
don't touch me bro
no charge on you do fan hey 25 sighs
okay
hey nobody don't touch me you're just
too fat so no okay this is our safe spot
this is a house in the middle of a dream
house in the middle of my dreams
as soon as I jump down he's gonna be
like hey what's up hips okay don't hey
what's up me I'm not a fan
okay the elevator works now we got the
key right okay all right well it's been
fun playing out less videos I think this
will be the last episode I'm a little
sad this is over because I think you
bros really like that and I really liked
it and it's like what are we gonna do
with our life after this is over I guess
we can watch amnesia how much down are
we going
how much down can you go to the town of
continent like a my reflection look at
my erection I don't have a reflection
because I find or not what find another
way out
oh thanks what's wrong with doors in
this game whoa what that freak on a
stake whoa aah aah that is way too
laughs what is this place plot twist no
no no one
I hear the ending is interesting at
least
so we'll see I think I think we're
coming clear [ __ ] merlocks all right
what's up
follow the blood they said I shocked
look how fancy this place is look how
nice they fit sir that's so nice all
right
confidential not anymore
and I never read them anyway
well oh don't mind me just gonna go in
this creepy little bunker it's not a guy
how you doing there sir okay no more
jump scares please seriously why would
they kill each other stupid you don't do
that what is this place why is it white
look like salt or coke morphogenetic
engine you what that freckie mecha are
they making drugs
is that it
now they're making lunch well that makes
sense at least you're at the phone you
like it come on don't look like you're
that like a diet how can you say you
wouldn't eat this oh I'm sorry you grow
up grow up eating real food miss fancy
chains
I'm just kidding I just done come not
anymore
uh-huh I do believe this is patients one
to interview today okay very very very
very interesting hello hello let's see
they put these so they're rocks isn't
crack very interesting put Daisy what
idiot got a jump over them look how tall
I am now maybe we're supposed to climb
on these I think yes ow
made me hit my head oh [ __ ]
all right what do we got
what boss it was you over here you
[ __ ] raka maka phone hi exit
yep I'm going - yeah you did - yeah yeah
you discuss
oh no oh no but I didn't want to go home
you're [ __ ] mad I just wanna go home
take me home country road to the plague
but whoa whoa the walrider likes the
wall right I get it
don't touch me well let that Rockets
going on
I do believe that's my cue to get the
[ __ ] out of here hi
it's been wonderful what [ __ ] Billy
that's good
got discovered in my research of work
around turn its assets in human body
it's the natural function of cells to
produce molecules but through
psychosomatic direction we mentioned yet
some precise molecules necessary my body
it was foolish and wrong to think we
could control it to your smell and look
at the cause look what you did but how
but believes my friend
[ __ ] Bailey's going down alright for his
last episode coming up soon
tomorrow I'm sorry I keep you waiting
it's a it's an ending worth waiting for
I think he wasn't gonna dig it it's this
guy to come over today I'll see you in
the next one stay awesome bros charging
yet talking abou